let me introduce Dr Diana Gregg she is
the managing director of the explore
energy program at the pre-court
institute for energy here at Stanford uh
explore energy is a student engagement
program and it's helped students
navigate just the the variety and number
of opportunities including courses
Majors internships job opportunities
that are related to energy across all of
Stanford 7 schools in addition she I
feel like she kind of teaches the the
class version of that which is
understand energy in the fall and the
spring we'll learn a little bit more
about it but from what I understand is
kind of a broad overview of energy from
a lot of different perspectives
including policy perspective including
economics including science and so she
sort of sits at the web of all these
different opportunities and teaches this
course that sort of explores energy from
all these different angles and she is
very well qualified to do that so Dr
gragg's background is she has a
bachelor's degree in in chemical
engineering
she has Ms and PhD degrees in atmosph
from the atmosphere energy program in
civil and environmental engineering here
at Stanford but in addition to that she
was a Schneider fellow at the natural
resources defense Council in D.C she
worked at the Dow Chemical Company as a
production engineer and as a project
lead on Energy Efficiency projects and
she was a postdoctoral scholar here
investigating different areas of
sustainable transition or Transportation
excuse me so she's done a variety of
things and she brings that really
valuable perspective to this particular
Challenge and today she'll be talking
about the accelerating energy transition
and again we're really excited to have
you here uh Dr Greg and we look forward
to learning more about it
awesome thank you so much Paxson thank
you for that that introduction
um so welcome everyone I'm really happy
to be with you here today uh talking
about the accelerating energy transition
um so I got a nice introduction so we'll
skip that and really today I want to
explore with you where our energy comes
from today
um talk to you about what do we mean
when we talk about energy
why we care about energy so I'm going to
list some of the reasons that we think
we should care about energy and you can
think about your own reasons about why
you care about energy and some of the
exciting things that are happening
um which we're calling here the
accelerating energy transition there's a
lot of drivers for energy transition
we'll talk about those when we talk
about why we care about energy
um and it's it's really an exciting time
in the energy industry I would say
there's a lot of aspects of the energy
industry that have been doing the same
thing for a long time but now here we
are today we are making dramatic changes
in a lot of our energy industry so it is
it's a dynamic system that is that is
changing a lot and so that that can be
pretty exciting
okay so first I want to just give you a
landscape what do we mean when we talk
about energy
um so when we're talking about energy
we're really talking about what what do
humans want we want Energy Services and
that's where we should start when we're
thinking about energy we as humans we
want heating we want cooking we want
lighting we want transportation we want
our our cell phones charged our
computers charged we want
um our comfort and our and our in our
spaces those are Energy Services and to
there's a number of ways to get those
Energy Services and so what we do is we
take the energy resources that exist
those are our primary energy resources
they that's our fossil fuels the Sun the
wind things like that we take those
primary energy resources and we have to
convert them to get the Energy Services
we want
they don't often exist in the ways that
we want them for our Energy Services and
so the way we do that is through
secondary energy or energy currencies
and so that's things that you're very
familiar with like electricity like
gasoline for your car
those are care energy carriers we've
taken that primary resource we've
converted it to something that is more
useful for our Energy Services and so
that's the landscape we're talking about
I added another box on here talking
about energy storage
because especially for something like
electricity we have to match when we
want those services to win that
electricity Supply is
and so we have to think about how do we
store how do we make available some of
these these Energy Services when we want
them and so energy storage is an
important aspect of that
okay so I also want you to think about
now that we've kind of framed what
energy is in terms of this providing
these services that humans want I want
you to think about energy in terms of a
system and this is going to be important
as we're talking about transitioning to
a different Energy System for the future
we have to think about this as a whole
system and so on here I've put these are
the two largest Energy Systems in our
world today we have oil providing
transportation services and we have coal
providing other electricity services and
so those are still today the two largest
Energy Systems we have in the world and
there's a lot of different steps in
these Energy Systems
so you can see
the primary energy is the the energy
that we have those are our resources
that we have on our planet we convert
them to something that's more useful
taking the coal example we're putting it
into an electricity generation
this is where a lot of the efficiency
loss happens in this system
and so when we're putting coal into that
that power station we're only getting
about a third of the energy out is
something that's useful this is the
significant Energy Efficiency loss in
the system we're making it onto
electricity and then we're providing the
electricity service that we need need
so when we're looking at these two
largest systems
I put kind of this this triangle to
think about the efficiency of these
systems so if we're putting in 100 units
to think of those units as any sort of
energy unit of that resource in
um in this system we're only getting
about one to ten units of energy service
out and that's because of these large
losses in this system for the oil system
a lot of the losses happen right in our
automobiles where we're actually putting
that oil in as a heat engine in a very
inefficient Manner and so as we're
thinking about how do we provide these
Human Services that we need for the
future by using less of these energy
resources the first thing we need to
think about is how to make these these
systems and provide these services in a
more efficient way
so that's just framing how to think
about energy so I want to give you a
sense of where we're at today what is
providing our our energy needs today and
so I've got four pie charts up here
showing both the resources that provide
our energy overall and then a subset of
that which is just electricity
generation and I'm showing it for both
the world and the United States and both
of these and all of these you can see
that fossil fuels really dominate our
Energy System uh probably not a surprise
to anyone
um but it dominates our Energy System
and has for a long time so you can see
for energy we're around 80 percent
um of our energy is provided by fossil
fuels electricity it's more like 60
percent of our systems are provided by
fossil fuels the biggest difference when
we're talking about energy to
electricity is transportation and also
industrial heat and other heat needs so
you'll see in our fossil fuels really we
we don't use oil for electricity we
primarily use oil for our transportation
systems so you see oil is almost zero
percent or two percent in both of our
electricity charts only really using oil
for electricity in places where it's
hard to have other resources
uh like island nations for example might
use oil for electricity otherwise oil is
a very high energy dense fuel
both from a volume standpoint and a
weight standpoint and so it's actually
been really effective to use as a
transportation fuel from that point and
so that makes it really hard to find
other uses or other fuels to to power a
transportation system and so as we get
into this and as we start talking later
in today's lecture about
decarbonizing our Energy System this
gives you a sense of the challenge of
that oil is is in particular is a really
tough challenge because of that energy
density of oil
okay so that's giving you a snapshot I
also just wanted to give one example of
over time so this is the United States
electricity sector
um since you know 1952 today and showing
you what it what we were really relying
on for the electricity demand at the
time so that's 100 as our as our
electricity demand and you can see over
time
um we have really weaned ourselves off
of oil for any sort of in our
electricity system a lot of that was
caused by policies
um after the Arab oil embargo in the
late 1970s which really made oil just
too expensive to use for electricity
when it was so valuable for a
transportation Fuel and then you can see
our our coal system uh here in the
United States coal is is really on this
this fast decline really peaked in 2008
and has been on a decline ever since in
our electricity system and that the that
is really because even existing
coal-fired power plants cannot compete
with new wind solar and natural gas
power plants both on a cost standpoint
and in just in dealing with a lot of the
waste streams that come with coal with
coal you have to deal with coal ash out
the the back end of a Generating Station
you have to deal with Mercury and sulfur
emissions out the stocks natural gas
wind and solar don't have some of those
challenges and so coal has really been
on this decline As Natural Gas wind and
solar
have really been more cost effective
in addition to policy encouragements but
even on an unsubsidized manner when
solar natural gas are cheaper options
and are becoming to dominate our
electricity system
nuclear and hydro haven't changed a lot
but
um nuclear is also on the decline again
it also is having trouble competing
um even existing nuclear with new wind
and solar because they've become such a
low-cost electricity source so we're
going to see renewable energy growing
more but you can see and it's growing
quickly but you can see it's growing
from a pretty small amount so this is a
long way from from really being a
decarbonized system we're still you know
60 percent dependent on on fossil fuels
okay so that really gives you a sense of
where we are today I want to talk about
why we care why do we care about energy
from all these different aspects there
are economic reasons that we care about
energy we need those Energy Services and
we want them to be cost cost effective
ways to get those Energy Services there
are political reasons we care about
energy we think about energy security
foreign policy security and stability
there are environmental reasons that we
care about energy so climate change air
pollution other environmental impacts on
our water systems
things like that that's a reason we care
about the environment ethical reasons so
human development Equity or reasons we
care about energy because it's so key to
those Energy Services we need and then
you know medical access and diseases and
I think this was really highlighted with
the covid pandemic we've really seen
um some of the importance for energy in
terms of medical access and
um and how important some of that
aspects of that are in addition to some
diseases spreading from climate change
so all of these are reasons we care
about energy and so I'm just going to
give some examples in these categories
of why we we care about energy why it is
so important
I'm going to start
um with economics and energy security
and so one of the framings we talk about
when we're talking about the impacts of
something is social costs versus private
costs so private costs are what we pay
what we pay for the gallon of gas what
we pay for
um electricity that's our private cost
the social cost is the private Cost Plus
any externalities for for using that
that resource and so an easy example is
you know for a gallon of gasoline I'm
paying
um you know three 350 for a gallon of
gasoline the externalities of using that
are air pollution our climate change and
so Society is bearing some of those
costs that aren't included in the
private costs so that's the social cost
and so this is just an economic
framework and thinking about that and a
lot of times our policies are meant to
try to incorporate more of those
externalities into the private costs so
Society isn't isn't bearing those those
costs and so it's a way to go back and
forth
and so I like to use this this cartoon
to kind of show
um
an example of this and so this cartoon
of the person's come up to the gas
station to get by a gallon of gasoline
which is a thousand dollars a gallon
um and the person saying well the gas is
only you know three dollars four dollars
but there is this military aspect
there's these additional social costs
um associated with that gallon of
gasoline and so that is this framework
and then we think about how can we
more accurately price some of the
private costs and how can we do that in
an equitable Manner and that then that
gets that gets challenging and so some
of the externalities for this example
for oil
um you know there's the military aspect
for Access of oil especially when it's
so important to so many economies around
the world
um there's air pollution water pollution
and there's land use there's climate
change aspects of of our oil use
and then there are taxes and subsidies
associated with this so although
thinking about this in this framework it
might make sense that we were trying to
incorporate externalities into private
costs that's not always the case some
policies actually lower private costs
and then Society is bearing more of
those those externalities because the
the commodity isn't isn't accurately
priced
um and so there's some things like
gasoline taxes that move those
externalities into private costs and
there's some things that are more about
like like here in the US we have
subsidies to try to encourage domestic
oil production and that's more from an
energy security standpoint and so some
policies are are kind of moving this in
in both directions so just just to give
an example of one reason we care about
energy and and our systems is it's it's
important in all these different aspects
um of Our Lives
I'm going to continue on the oil example
because I think it's pretty illustrative
for another reason we care about oil um
our our Energy Systems and that's
foreign policy and trade and this one
comes up a lot a lot of people are
surprised to learn that Canada is
actually the the country that the US
Imports the most oil from
um and that's because a lot of the
energy security
concerns that come up around oil for the
United States often have to do with OPEC
countries Saudi Arabia Russia in
particular most recently
um but it definitely complicates foreign
trade and policy and so it makes it
challenging I would say for all you know
for governments when they have a
resource that's so important to their
economy and they're dependent on it from
other countries it really complicates
those relationships
um and so we see that a lot when
um with with Saudi Arabia being really a
swing country in terms of oil production
and oil price that that impacts how for
example U.S governments
um and U.S presidents might interact
with Saudi Arabia and so certainly this
this kind of dependence is another
reason we care about
um
foreign policy and trade is another
reason we care about these these Energy
Systems
one of the things I like to point out is
you know we get a lot of our at least
our imported oil from Canada
um generally considered a friendly
country with with the United States
um but it is also a very carbon
intensive and land intensive type of oil
much of the oil coming from Canada is in
oil sands or sometimes called tar Sands
and so what we're importing from from
Canadian Oil
often can have just an increased carbon
intensity and environmental impact than
other places so another aspect and
reason we care about energy
okay I think one of the reasons we care
and then we're just following on the
geopolitics of this and I think this has
been highlighted a lot with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
um Europe has has long depended on on
Russia for much of its natural gas this
is just giving you a sense of how much
the European Union has depended on on
Russian supply of natural gas over the
years starting in 2001 around 30 percent
got up to a peak around uh 2018 2019 of
over 45 percent
um and then you can see the major drop
through concerted efforts on the part of
the European Union after Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
um and so Russia has used this Reliance
on natural gas as
um you know a power play in terms of of
impacting policies and things
um from that International relationship
and so again energy is important because
it has not only these important parts of
our Energy Services but these
geopolitical challenges as well and
certainly the invasion of Ukraine was
not the first time that that Russia has
used it Europe's Reliance on its natural
gas as something to try to influence
policy in between Europe and Russia and
so we've seen you know I've marked some
of these places where they've they've
cut the gas to Ukraine for example
um uh as a you know a political tool so
this is just another reason that the
energy systems are really important and
it gets complicated
I'm going to switch gears a little bit
from geopolitics to talk more about
equity and human development
so another reason we care about energy
is the global energy consumption for
modern sources of energy are highly
inequitable there are countries that
have have a lot of access like the
United States to Modern sources of
energy and have for a long time and
there are other places in the world
where this is very limited and so what
I'm showing you here is primary energy
consumption for different countries and
then trying to give you a sense of some
of these countries on what what how that
relates to their population so you can
see United States we have about four
percent of the world's population use 16
of the world's energy China which has
had a lot of energy consumption growth
as its economy has grown has 18 of the
world's population
um uses about 26 percent of the world's
energy
and then places like oops
I'm not sure what happened places like
Africa
um use have 18 overall population and
use a very small portion of the world's
energy and so it is it is highly in
inequitable in terms of access to
um energy and that has impacts on on
human development and economic activity
and so this is another reason if we're
worrying about human development
worldwide globally
um this is another reason we care about
energy
one of the measures that we use to look
at human development is the human
development development index
and that access to Modern energy is
really important um it's highly
coordinated with income and quality of
life especially on the low end
and so if you're looking at this this
chart I apologize if it's a little small
but on the y-axis I'm I've got human
development index on the x-axis I've got
electricity use per capita
and so you can see if you've kind of
just glanced on a lot of these countries
um to really get up the human
development index
on the left hand side you
you really
um having a little bit more access to
electricity as a modern energy resource
really helps you move up the human
development index
at some point you get to the point where
you're you know you're in this kind of
developed world uh category and you can
see there's a wide scatter of
electricity use per capita but uh many
of these countries that that additional
electricity use doesn't actually lead to
an increase in human development and so
this chart is telling you two things
that on the developing side of things
access to Modern energy resources is
really important and it's also telling
you that for the developed World there
are likely more efficient ways that we
can use our energy access and maintain a
high quality human development and so
both of those things really need to
happen as we're looking to transition
our Energy Systems uh into the into the
future
another reason we care about energy is
the environmental and social
consequences and other ethical issues
and so the first thing I'm showing you
here is that we care about and we impact
environmental and social
um
parts of our planet on all parts of our
Energy System so I showed you Energy
Systems earlier and so we have
everything from the resource to the
service you know from extraction of the
resource all the way down to what we
want as humans there are impacts on this
this whole system
for many of our of our energy resources
and so there are land use impacts
um for our energy resources we care
about the water
contamination availability of water how
we're using water
atmosphere so both air pollution and
climate change are are significant
impacts I will talk a little bit more
about air pollution and climate change
next because those are those are
significant both locally and globally
Wildlife so as we have land use change
we have habitat
encroachment and destruction species
Extinction that that we worry about
health and safety so from a human
standpoint a lot of the extraction
especially businesses sometimes the
refining businesses
um Can can be
more more dangerous or have more risk
that has to be managed and so that is a
challenge with our energy use
we get
um I put it as this category of
annoyance but there are definitely
um we call them NIMBY issues not my
backyard issues
um with a lot of our energy use so that
is is a social impact for my energy use
and those those are just categories but
there's also long-term impacts so
intergenerational
um and the big ones I I think I've
listed kind of the big ones here climate
change is when we're going to talk about
more nuclear waste is another one that
we have not resolved
um radioactive waste from our nuclear
power plants is radioactive for 200 000
years
ish and we don't have long-term
Solutions on keeping people safe for
that kind of time frame and so those are
unresolved issues with our energy
systems that we have today
and then finally there's environmental
justice uh and so I'll give an example
of that next but
um the you know thinking about energy
equity and environmental justice those
are there's a lot of ethical issues on
how we've extracted our energy resources
how we're using them and who is bearing
more of the social costs of of those
Energy Services and so those are all
challenges that that we see and reasons
we care
so just to give an example of that last
one I'm talking about air pollution uh
so air pollution
um is more deadly than people often
think so globally air pollution kills an
extra estimated 7 million people in the
world here in the United States it's
around a hundred thousand people every
year
um have premature mortality uh because
of air pollution and those effects are
felt disproportionately by different
people and so this is a Harvard study
that was done in the United States
um the you know basically
um black people were three times more
likely to die from exposure than from
Airborne pollutants than other groups
and it's it's inequitable so what this
chart is showing you on the left is the
air pollution emitted meaning what what
benefit did they get from the Energy
Service being provided from the air
pollution that is being emitted and on
the right is the air pollution that is
that is being inhaled by those
populations so
um just to show you that it's
disproportionate
for these different groups in terms of
how much impact they're getting compared
to the benefit that they're getting from
the services and so there's a
significant energy Equity challenge with
our Energy Systems we have today
and leaving the biggest uh I would say
the elephant in the room to the last
honor reasons we care about energy
talking about climate change so energy
is the biggest piece of the pie of what
is contributing to greenhouse gas
emissions uh and and climate change and
so this is in all sorts of different
sectors this is kind of broken down into
Transportation industry use and
buildings different ways to look at it
but energy is the biggest piece and so
it is a reason we care about energy and
of course we are constantly seeing
um I would say more and more each year
the impacts of of climate change and so
um these are just giving some examples
you know we see record Heats we see
wildfires we see hurricanes most
recently here in the United States we
we've and North America we've seen the
wildfires in Canada where
um it is is unprecedented and we keep
hearing that unprecedented
um
you know wildfires or storms from
climate change and so I'm showing you
here what the wildfires look like uh
this year for Canada and how that
impacted
um the Northeast so this is showing the
skyline of New York
um kind of on a normal day and then
during the when the when the wildfires
smoke was being blown in from from
Canada
and so on climate change uh it is uh one
of those those long-term Legacy
intergenerational challenges with our
Energy System
that we're seeing the impacts of today
and when we're talking about equity and
Justice a lot of the communities that
are going to have the hardest time
dealing with the impacts of climate
change are the ones that don't have the
resources to do so and so a lot of this
is a major challenge to our Energy
Systems when we're talking about
um
maintaining our planet for for human
life and so I'm giving you this this is
a chart from a a Stanford
um group showing the global the global
carbon project so you can see more about
that website if you want to dig into the
data a little bit more but there's we
really have a carbon budget and if we
want to keep from going over this one
and a half degrees Celsius that we hear
about in the media we hear about from
the ipcc we're about at 1.1 degrees
Celsius now
um we have a very little time to get to
a zero carbon or even a carbon negative
um Energy System
um we are going to run out of that that
budget
um in in the next
um
10 to 10 to 20 years and so there this
is a very urgent need for transitioning
our our Energy Systems
okay so that is some of the reasons why
uh we should care about energy and you
know hopefully you've thought about
yourself why why you care about energy
and what what aspects um are most
interesting to you
the last little bit of today's webinar I
want to talk about how things can change
and how things are changing
um because I mentioned you know our
energy systems for a long time weren't
changing a lot
um and in the last couple decades
they've really seen shifts and all sorts
of different aspects on how we're
supplying the Energy Services people
need and so this is just one
um estimate of of what it will take to
finance the transition to Net Zero by
2050. there are a lot of estimates out
there but this is one guidance I would
say of looking at these different
sectors
and how much
investment it will take to transition
the transition is in different phases
for different things I would say in a
lot of it like in electricity we have
Solutions today and in a lot of places
those Solutions are cost effective to
decarbonize those systems and so it is
more of an implementation phase
transportation is just getting started
and there are hard to decarbonize
sectors of our transportation like our
long haul that we really haven't figured
out buildings we know what to do and a
lot of that and so it's an
implementation so there's a lot of
different places that these energy
systems are at so we can continue to
grow the Energy Services that we're
providing and use less less energy and
and less greenhouse gas emissions to do
so
so the first one I want to point out is
Energy Efficiency
okay so this chart was developed by a
man named Amory Lovins who
um was the co-founder of the rock of
Rocky Mountain Institute it is a think
tank that works on integrative design
and other solutions to a lot of these
these challenges and really the the main
point I wanted you to get from from this
chart as I as I describe it is that
Energy Efficiency is a really important
aspect
to providing Energy Services we need and
using less energy to do so it is the the
most cost effective tool we have
um in our tool in our tool chest and so
what this chart is showing you this is
showing U.S primary energy consumption
um and this chart was made in the in the
1970s and so at the time
this this blue line is what the US
government thought our energy needs were
going to be and Amory Levins proposed
that no will get smarter about how we
use energy and he proposed what he calls
a soft path this this black line what
we've actually done is is this red line
um and so
the the
big Point here is that Energy Efficiency
has done a lot more to reduce the use of
our fossil fuels than Renewables and
that that should continue into the
future so what do I mean by Energy
Efficiency because sometimes it's
convert it's um
it's confused with energy conservation
Energy Efficiency is providing the same
or even better service
um using less energy to do it
um and so there's there's a lot of
examples of that I think lighting is
usually the one that comes to mind for
people
um where instead of using an
incandescent light bulb you use a an LED
you're still getting your your lighting
service even a better lighting service
because it's not providing heat as well
it's a so you don't have to provide
Cooling and things like that because
it's coming off of your light but using
less energy to do it and that is a key
point to try to decarbonize we need to
do an energy efficiency because it makes
the decarbonization of our Energy
Systems so much easier
so this chart was developed by McKenzie
looking at
ways to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
so ways to reduce carbon emissions
and you can see everything here on the
left a lot of these are Energy
Efficiency measures and they are cost
negative meaning that implementation of
these might have some costs up front but
you save money over time and again you
should be getting the same or better
service we see this in in green
buildings where people often have
natural light instead of artificial
light they have more insulation so their
spaces are more comfortable and you get
increased productivity or increased
happiness from people in those buildings
and so it's providing a better service
using less energy to do so and so this
is our biggest tool this is our biggest
impact the challenges with Energy
Efficiency so so definitely not to
um
say that it's easy to do Energy
Efficiency
um one of my my favorite quotes from
Energy Efficiency professor at Stanford
was that it's not twenty dollars it's
two thousand pennies
Energy Efficiency does take knowledge of
things like integrative design it takes
intention it takes a willingness not to
do things as we've always done it but to
try to find new ways to provide the
energy Services we want
um that we'll use less energy to do so
so it it does take effort on the front
end to implement Energy Efficiency
all right the next one that we talk
about transitions usually is this
transition and growth and renewable
energy
um very very exciting when I really got
into
um working in an energy and energy
industry you know in the early 2000s
um we didn't think solar was ever going
to be cost effective and now we're at a
point today where wind and solar really
are our most cost effective
um ways to produce new electricity
um and so they're being installed at a
rapid rate uh and so this is a huge tool
in the tool set for decarbonizing our
electricity sector is the growth and
wind and solar as they become cost
effective
and we see that so this is just showing
you new capacity editions in the United
States and and solar is almost almost
half of those
transportation is more challenging
um so this is just a chart looking at um
how efficient our transportation systems
are from from this excellent book
resource Revolution that I've I've put
here in the bottom
um showing that we're not very efficient
about how we use our cars it's a lot of
capital investment to not using it very
much
the Motive Power in our cars is not very
efficient um using a little heat engine
in our cars is not a very efficient way
to do it and then even the
infrastructure and how often we're using
the roads
um and the bridges and everything that
we put into our transportation
infrastructure is not very efficient and
so there are ways that all of these are
being addressed by new modes of
transportation by you know autonomous
vehicles things like that that I think
are going to change a lot of our
transportation system I just want to
talk for a minute about electrification
of our transportation system because
that automatically makes our
transportation much more efficient so
using an electric motor instead of
internal combustion engine or a diesel
engine in your in your vehicle
automatically makes it much more
efficient electric motors are can be you
know 90 efficient
um our heat engines you know are often
more like 25 to 35 percent efficient and
so it is this automatic efficiency game
that you get in addition to the other
benefits of electrification of our
transportation one of them being that it
really diversifies our fuels and so
you can see that when we're starting to
get
um our fuel for our transportation
system from the electricity system we
now have Diversified where we're getting
those fuels it's not just just from oil
and we see carbon emission benefits
um right away or we can see them as we
we decarbonize the electricity system
overall and so that that is a big
opportunity for decarbonizing one of our
biggest systems which is transportation
so we're seeing countries do this all
over the world Norway has made a huge
Highway into adopting electric vehicles
through some beneficial policy that they
have in place we see targets here in the
United States for growing electric
vehicles
um and China has has one of the largest
markets for electric vehicles so that
does not mean that the electric vehicles
are not without challenges so they work
really well for passenger vehicles it's
harder for a longer haul still a lot of
work there and then we have to think
about where we're getting the resources
for our batteries and so those are all
challenges that still remain in this
aspect of decarbonizing our systems
I mentioned you know batteries and
battery storage so we're not just using
them in our vehicles we're using them on
our electricity system making our
electricity systems
um more resilient and better able to
incorporate
um things like like wind and solar and
as battery prices have come down along
with solar and wind prices we're really
seeing that even a solar system Plus
batteries is cheaper than running an
existing coal or an existing nuclear
plant in the United States and so they
are able to bid in at a lower cost and
so we're seeing this dramatic transition
um happening in our electricity system
with the electrification of
Transportation with the
um the growth in
residents and users providing their own
electricity Supply like with solar
panels on their roofs with
electrification of buildings
um where we're electrifying appliances
stoves and heaters and things like that
we are going to see a whole new system
where our transportation our homes and
our electricity
grid is all interconnected in new ways
and so there's a lot of growth there and
all of this is a transition that's
that's happening and that is going to
lead to more decarbonization
and the last a couple minutes I want to
just give highlight for some transitions
that are just on the cusp that aren't
really happening yet but are poised to
and I would say you would see the the
increase of these um coming so
geothermal is one we've used geothermal
resources for a long time to provide
electricity but there are new advents
um about the the
um way we're getting these geothermal
resources and making use of them that
means geothermal is going to grow and be
a growing portion of decarbonizing our
electricity systems
hydrogen is upcoming I would say
hydrogen has been looked at as a way to
decarbonize some of the the more
challenging ways to decarbonize our our
systems and so you will see more and
more investment and talk about hydrogen
um for for filling some of those
challenging roles
and then even fusion fusion is getting a
lot of attention right now a lot of
growth and startups and looking at how
we can advance this
um and have it be part of our solution
and and finally carbon capture and
storage is getting a lot of attention so
how do we get to
um you know zero carbon or even carbon
negative
um carbon capture and storage will will
be a a piece of that solution
so finally you know this is this is what
our our passes look like for energy
consumption definitely still in this oil
and gas age but we need to quickly
remove into this clean energy age and
we'll just have to see how fast we can
make that happen
so with that I'm sorry I did wasn't able
to answer your questions along the way
hopefully uh some of the Q a was
answered as we went
um and I'm happy to to do what's next so
thank you all for your attention
thanks Dan I know we're at times as a
fantastic presentation I really
appreciate you taking the time we did
have a a couple questions that came in
so maybe
um maybe we just focus on on three short
ones uh so one you know do you have do
you have any predictions or how are you
feeling in terms of how optimistic are
you about this transition that you laid
out do you say want to say if you do you
feel bold enough to say a few words
right now about that yeah I'm happy to
so I will just say that I am a mom of
four and so I feel like that that drives
me that I need to be optimistic and
um I think in the past we've had
transitions happen a lot faster than we
thought
um cell phones you know became
ubiquitous a lot faster than with
thought and smartphones we've
transitioned
um you know from from zero cars to
millions of cars very quickly I think we
can do this with the right incentives
and so there are a lot of people around
the world that are working on this so it
just makes me optimistic and so I see
that every day in students and things
like that the thing I'm most excited
about I just know personally is um I've
worked a lot on transportation and so
electrification of transportation is
something I've seen come a long way over
the last 20 years and I'm really excited
about the Innovations there and the
possibilities
and maybe as a transition as a kind of a
final question is so you do teach a
class understand energy at Stanford it
is available for professionals to enroll
in as a we call non-degree student and
I'm matriculated student you can find a
link there could you say a little bit
about that that class and how uh you
know how you're thinking about it in
terms of this larger transition and
maybe even as part of that if you could
speak a little bit more about pre-court
and what you see your role in this
larger what you're doing as an educator
in this area yeah yeah absolutely so the
first thing on the course we teach
um obviously we go into more into depth
and all of these different aspects and
we go through each energy resource so
oil coal winds geothermal
um and really talk about all the aspects
of it the technical the political the
regulatory the environmental impacts the
potential so you really get an in-depth
dive to each of our energy resources and
then we also talk about cross-cutting
things so like Transportation buildings
Energy Efficiency as those kind of
topics and so it is an intense in depth
to all of those but it is designed to be
um for anybody so you don't have to be
an energy expert to come take our course
this is really
introductory to all of these where you
don't need any
um you know prerequisites for for our
course a pre-court Institute for energy
so this is
um the the Premier energy Institute at
Stanford has a lot of initiatives around
research in a lot of these different
areas and is working closely with the
Stanford school for sustainability and
how to get a lot of those that research
to scale and and be impactful in the
world and so
um I would say we at pre-court have a
a responsibility for Education
responsibility for for research and then
a responsibility for getting that
education research out to the world so
it's impactful and so all of those
things are happening at pre-court and uh
and our partnership with the Stanford
door School of sustainability
thank you Dr Gregg we got a lot of
questions we didn't get to to most of
them but we do have a do want to make
sure respect that everyone's time who
joined and also Dr Greg's time so thank
you so much we've got all those those
questions if you answer the the survey
question there as well we'll share them
with Dr regg maybe we have to do a
follow-up webinar on some of these
questions that are coming in so thank
you everybody we really appreciate you
being here today thank you Dr Greg yeah
thank you everyone